si à compter du confinement strict
observé il y a eu moins de contacts
entre les personnes si le virus et donc
moins transmis grâce aux gestes
barrières et à la distance minimale d'un
mètre entre nous alors après la période
d'incubation moyenne de 7 jours et la
durée moyenne d'évolution 17 des
symptômes d'environ 7 jours aussi avant
l'apparition d'une détresse respiratoire
aiguë qui nécessite alors un passage en
réanimation
nous devrions observer une réduction du
nombre de personnes nécessitant une
admission en réanimation à partir de la
fin de cette semaine
2600 six décès ont été observés en
milieu hospitalier depuis le 1er mars
mais aussi et c'est important de le dire
7130 deux personnes sont sortis guéris
de l'hôpital depuis la même date
toutes les personnes détectées positive
en ville ou diagnostiqués par leur
médecin traitant et qui au bout de huit
jours non plus de symptômes pendant 48
heures sont aussi guéris et elles sont
heureusement très nombreuses enfin vous
le savez nous avons cette surveillance
syndromique en population 2939 passage
en côte et enregistré hier aux urgences
pour suspicion de kovy 19 2423
intervention de sos médecins l'ont été
aussi motivé pour suspicion d'infection
qu'ovide 19
vous le savez nous surveillons enfin la
mortalité à l'échelon national le nombre
observé de décès sur la semaine 12 du 16
au 22 mars devient significativement
supérieur à celui attendu avec un excès
de mortalité de 9 % à l'échelon régional
une hausse de la mortalité par rapport à
l'attendu tous âges confondus est
observée dans cinq régions grand test au
de france bourgogne franche-comté
ile-de-france et corse
la surmortalité concerne des personnes
de plus de 65 ans enfin les résultats
des tests
à ce jour plus de 40000 174 tests
positifs ont été notifiés à santé
publique france